uh I want to play a clip for you guys
today which I believe is a perfect
example of how democrats should be
dealing with these neo-reactionary
Republicans in the House of
Representatives and in the Senate you
know what one of the conversations we've
had uh over the last few years is that
even though the right has absolutely no
minimum standard whatsoever for what
they want what they won't do what
they're not willing to do
we on the left shouldn't sink to their
level in the sense of telling straight
up lies fabricating imaginary social
issues employing horrifying double
standards uh uh personal attacks all of
these different things but what
democrats should appeal to
is the Public's sort of sense of justice
and emotions in order to get them to
understand the stakes of so many things
this is really one for the ages uh
Congressman Jamie Raskin a Democrat who
I'm a fan of I like Jamie Raskin I've
talked about him before
he ripped Marjorie Taylor green to
shreds after during a floor debate
supposedly about Ukraine it's supposedly
about the brutal invasion of Ukraine by
Vladimir Putin
she said nothing about it she instead
talked about the southern border and
made a whole bunch of other a completely
fact-free claims and Jamie Raskin takes
her to task and I wish more Democrats in
the house day in and day out spoke about
their extremist Republican colleagues in
this way maybe it could help him hold
the house in November take a look at
this attack Ed it's a shame it's a
tragedy I yield back the remainder of
Reserve
gentlemen gentlemen's times expired
gentleman from Pennsylvania reserves
gentleman from Maryland's recognized Mr
Speaker the United States of America
just witnessed witnessed the most
astonishing spectacle
we are here to debate
Aid to the people of Ukraine defending
themselves against a massive Invasion by
Vladimir Putin and his army right
then
the minority puts up the distinguished
General lady from Georgia who does not
mention Ukraine once and by the way yes
I believe his use of the term
distinguished gentle lady about Marjorie
Taylor green I believe it's it's
tongue-in-cheek she does not mention the
thousands of Ukrainian civilians who've
been slaughtered by Putin's Army she
does not mention more than 100 Ukrainian
children who've been shot and killed by
the Ukrainian Army instead she talks
about a massive Invasion at the border a
massive Invasion which their own
speakers have said today hundreds of
thousands of people have been
apprehended in
that's very different from a military
Invasion the one in Ukraine of course
the gentlelady is not going to talk
about that
she had a lot to say the other day when
she heckled me continuously
when I came to the floor it was like The
Rocky Horror Picture Show in here with
her chanting about the Russia hoax and
Russia this and Russia that now she had
the opportunity to tell the world what
her views about Russia are I put them
out there exactly what she has said she
said that the aid that the taxpayers of
America are sending to the people of
Ukraine to defend themselves against
Vladimir Putin and the Russian army
falls into the hands of Nazis I want to
see her proof
where's our evidence
shocks about NATO Nazis
does my minority believe that our allies
in NATO who are trying to defend the
people of Ukraine are Nazis has it come
to this
gentlelady talked about a massive
Invasion we had a massive invasion of
our own chamber
and she continued to be a cheerleader
for the Insurrection this is exactly why
I keep talking about Jamie Raskin as
someone that I would support for
president of course depending on who
else is running and depending on what
his platform would be but in principle
someone I would support for president
he's a constitutional law professor he
actually knows the Constitution Marjorie
Taylor green loves to talk about the
Constitution Madison cawthorne loves to
claim that he's defending the
Constitution they don't know a damn
thing about it this is actually a
constitutional law professor Raskin was
a strong Progressive activist when he
was in the Maryland Senate he actually
worked with Republicans and moderate
Democrats and got things done he
sponsored bills to get rid of the death
penalty in Maryland to
um establish legal guidelines for
corporations to prevent them from raping
and pillaging the resources of the state
for their gain he
um worked he was on he was actually a
board member of fair vote which is an
interesting organization he sponsored
the first bill in the country for the
national popular vote I've talked about
so much which would be a way to get rid
of the Electoral College without
actually having to change the
Constitution he has this marijuana
reform all these different things this
is what has to be done we need a guy
like Raskin
talking about them as the extremists
that they are wanting everybody to have
health care is not the left equivalent
of supporting a coup they have nothing
to do with each other and the level of
extremism that we are seeing from the
right
requires and demands people like Raskin
who can speak in this way now raskin's
not the only guy I've talked about other
people I like as well but Democrats need
to be talking like this more frequently
and I'm glad to see him do it one of our
long time sponsors is vincero collective
if you don't know vincero yet it's the
place to go for Quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release is
no exception it's the Argo automatic it
spotlights everything I love about
vincero I got the Argo automatic in
Frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but I really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out I love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face I really
love all of their watches and I own a
bunch but the Argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero Collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below